oh my own my own wanderings through the
religious world are you know what other
wanderings I am I believe in the divine
but I don't think I believe in God that
makes any sense i believe in mystery I
believe in the sacred I believe that
within all of us is some sort of a light
and a loving force that can be very
easily darkened I think I don't believe
in the notion of good people and bad
people I don't I think that's one thing
I've always been writing about I don't
believe the good people exist here and
bad people here I believe we're all the
above and I don't think any
reprehensible behavior is beneath me I
don't think I'm above anything I'm a
human being however I pray over my kids
every night and and you know I was
raised Catholic released the first five
or six or eight years of my life so I do
the Sun at the cross but I just assume
do a jewish prayer or a Muslim prayer or
a Buddhist or Hindu meditation I'm
actually troubled by monotheism I have a
hard time with it but i but i believe in
the divine and i think we and i have a
hard time believing that when we're dead
that's it most days I think there's
something more mr.
yeah huge very devout went to Mass seven
mornings a week it's a big part of his
life you know prayed with the rosary but
I dodged that bullet and I shouldn't put
it that way but I kind of believe that's
what I dodged
I was forced I was forced I actually had
been to one as a young guys you know to
bachelor party which i found depressing
and expensive and when I was about 20 so
I had gotten a Guggenheim Fellowship so
I had money it was supposed to be used
for research and I thought well you know
I should use it to do this so I actually
had to go to my wife and say you know
honey I really need to go do some
research for this thing i'm working on
and and i did I flew to Florida and and
went to these clubs and interviewed some
dancers but I have to say to that I also
went to Florida to kind of smell Florida
and see the vegetation and to see it in
to feel the difference between Florida
and not Florida here I had this belief
that if you're trying to write
character-driven fiction then the heart
of the story is character and if the
heart of the story is character then
landscape in place are the lungs and
that characters can't breathe without it
there's also a wonderful line about this
from the right around Carlson who said
that details are for the writer only
they are the instruments by which we
steer so the essential details are
completely they're not the garnish on
the side of the plate there the meat and
potatoes they completely influence what
happens and where things go so I needed
to go there and planet it
you